often go through many technological
advancements that make our lives easier
in day to day life
for example if we talk about features
that we have in our mobiles and cameras
like face recognition object detection
image noise reduction text recognition
and what not
all thanks to open source libraries like
opencv which help the pcs to understand
the digital images content such as
photographs and videos
opencv stands for open source computer
vision library
the purpose of opencv is to understand
or extract the information from the
picture or the video and helps the
computer to perform the same kind of
tasks as humans do
one of the application of opencv
includes
converting images into cartoon animation
which is often used in filter nowadays
with opencv you can easily do that task
with the help of some basic functions
so if you are curious about learning the
opencv and how it works then we are here
to help you with that
get ready to start your opencv journey
with us
simply learn scale of course on learn
opencv course online will provide you
with all the necessary skills and
information like image processing
computer vision etc that you need to
know in order to master various tasks of
the opencv software library this free
course on learn opencv course online
will help you learn about object
detection color detection image
processing changing color space blending
two different images deep image
classification and much more in great
depth
this scale of course is especially
designed for beginners and the content
of the course is created by the
augmented startups who are industry
leaders with a vast experience in this
field
you can begin your opencv journey with
us free of cost
and also get a course completion
certificate for the same
the total duration of this free opencv
course is 5 hours and all the chapters
are self-paced video lessons with 90
days of access to the course
this allows you to learn at your own
pace and convenience
after completing the course
you will receive
a course completion certificate by
simply loan
this certificate can be added to your
resume to enhance your chances of
getting hired isn't that amazing
so now you might be thinking about if
you are eligible to take up this course
there are no prerequisites or
eligibility criteria to register for
this free course
yet a basic understanding of any
programming language
statistics and mathematics would be
highly beneficial
the average annual salary for a computer
vision developer is 107
998 dollars
and in india you can earn nearly 6 to 9
lakh per annum
so what you are waiting for head
straight to our scale up page and enroll
in our free learn open cv course online
today
sign up now and get certified with
simply learn
the link is in the description box
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here